well actually I've always been  interested in bees they're the pinnacle  of social evolution really in the whole  animal kingdom but my interest in their  gut bacteria in particular developed  when there was a study right after the  first colony collapse event which was  2007 there was a study of the organisms  associated with bees and attempt to find  what disease organism might be involved  and one thing that came out of that  didn't identify a disease organism but  it did show that there was a set number  of bacteria that live in every single  honeybee everywhere in the world and  that these are dominating the gut of  those bees and that made me think this  is a good system for really looking at a  at a very specialized community that's  probably doing something important in  bees